Missouri now where Michael Leung is
dishing up a bowl of incredible
well what's Michael doing the first one
is so slow it looks like Michaels made a
mistake but here's a quicker second bar
okay eight pins down where is that slow
ball honey it just looks like it's gonna
end up in the gutter it's smoking it's
hooking this is the slowest game a 10
pin ball I've ever seen is this game
over the mound
very serious
well that one's really cool Michael is
clearly an epic bowler with skills to
spare
how does he pull off his strange shot
Michael's first ball he gave loads of
vertical spin it's spinning incredibly
fast and it's resting on the tiny point
that it's spinning around this makes it
stable
it also means very little friction this
allows it to keep going all the way down
the lane but what is his slow ball snake
what's actually happening is the lanes a
little bit curved and because it's going
so slow it has time to react to that
curvature and change its direction it's
like the world's least extreme
skateboarding halfpipe
so Michael sends the ball down the lane
with enough energy to make it off the
microscopic slope and then gravity pulls
it back down towards the center
continues down the lane and it goes up a
little bit and then comes back down and
into the pins so through his epic skills
we've learned a very valuable lesson
which is that sometimes slower is better
thanks Vicky